[Music]
hey hey yeah yay eh yay eh yay eh yay eh
yay I don't feel like dancing you don't
fit now and keep sucked it was a a week
11 where there were blowouts there were
seemingly blowouts where teams came back
we we saw a lot of storylines come
crashing down where the Bears are
looking at each other going what the
hell the Rams are looking at each other
going what the hell the Eagles are
looking at each other and going what the
hell and then you have teams like
Minnesota that's like oh man we showed
some fight San Francisco oh man we
showed some fight and then you got the
Baltimore Ravens who i it gives me so
much joy there's a lot of stuff to get
into we're gonna have dolphin tank
Bengal tank we have an interview with
Grunk where I introduced Grunk to
pat-pat yes and I'm telling you that
I've never heard Gronk laugh like that
he loved pat pat so much that I thought
Gronk was gonna come back and play in
the NFL solely because of Pat right
there
like it was awesome did Pat Pat asked
him the most important question which is
are you coming back to the inner not
only did Pat Pat ask him that question
he asked it four different ways perfect
so you're gonna love that and then a
little bit later we'll get into the
Eagles and Patriots we're gonna save
that some before I guess we get into
Bengal tank / dolphin tank / I guess the
Giants were owned by tank the only thing
that we haven't been able to talk about
because I haven't seen you is the miles
Gerrit oh and the Kapernick situation
that's right two things so which one do
you want to talk about first well I
think the mouse Garrett is let's talk
about that one what is more fun even
though it was awful yeah yeah I you know
first of all let's start here and this
is probably not the best process place
to start because Garrett's was having a
great Dogma game before this happened
before all this went down he was having
a great game
he was probably the reason why they're
winning the doggone football games and
you're also putting your team in the
position to make a playoff run man that
an easy schedule coming up yes before
all this turmoil I kind of got Miami
next I kind of felt like things were
rounded into shape for the Browns was
this kind of weird to say because
they've been bad I'll tell you it's not
reasonable shape anymore Mesa Rudolph's
dented alright so let's get these truths
out of the way
mmm what miles Garrett did was awful of
course my Garrett should be suspended no
doubt it but there is no place on a
football field for that everybody knows
that even if we were to say things about
mason rudolph yeah
we are negative reduction of dome what
he did but we are we but miles you
[ __ ] up and went too far yes now
mm-hmm
I need to admit something okay there's
something about Mason Rudolph's face
that's hard for me to get angry at miles
Garrett because I was looking yeah but
look on his face he's got a Duke face
bro ah he's got a he's got a vision
later my dad is face Grayson Allen yeah
yeah he's got a he's got a you don't
know who you're messing with my dad's
the assistant DA until you get hit in
the head with the helmet that you can
start running to the reps like I just
think the funniest thing was like
watching all the media react to it it
was like somebody would go miles Garrett
should be kicked out of the league and
then then like I guess it was Max
Kellerman was like the leader of this
being like all of this is Mason
Rudolph's fault and it's no I do believe
that Mason Rudolph should be suspended
because I do have games would you
suspend him uh one OK reasonable I mean
that's what because I look at the other
guy Larry Hagman Joe be on the Browns
who just came up and pushed Rudolph he
got a game and that's what Mason looked
up at him was like but for me I guess I
I do believe that Miles Garrett started
it because it was unnecessary that he
brought Mason Rudolph and he held him
and brought him to the ground so this
whole Mesa we're gonna started no I
believe milestone it was kind of a late
hit yeah yeah and it was unnecessary and
it was sort of like I'm the big bully
and it was just unnecessary week yeah
yeah but it was it was unnecessary right
and Mason also you know he's thrown four
picks and he's frustrated
but on the ground he used every ounce of
his strength to try and pull that head
off that helmet off of miles Garrett all
of his everything and you know how tight
those helmets are I could imagine that
it feels like you're being choked you
know
so then Myles said okay you want to pull
my helmet I'll pull your helmet and he
pulled him off the ground and then with
all the - yes and that's I feel like if
it ended there it would have been fine
and then you got to Castro and then you
got Pouncy and there's n miles seems to
be calming down and then here comes
Mason he looked like a singer a kiss and
and what miles did was awful
yeah and disgusting and scary and I
guess that my point is is like okay it's
happening and he's suspended and like
whatever the NFL says I'm not here to
argue between three and six and I think
it should if you want to make at the end
of the season I get it I really do I
guess the thing that annoys me man is
everyone online that turns into the dude
at the pearly gates deciding whether you
go to heaven or hell as though Jim for
Mark and song is the most morally
phenomenal human being ever and I would
never do this right I don't know what
it's like to be in a place with 80,000
people yelling and the emotions of a
game and then I have a guy on the other
team pulling as hard as he can on my
head I probably wouldn't handle it well
would I do that I don't know that's my
issues the people that go I definitely
wouldn't do that for every one that's
ever spit on somebody and you just feel
that rage I know it's not equal I just I
don't like to judge people well yeah I
don't think you judge them you kind of
judge the circumstance though right I
think and I have felt raised before and
I have overstepped some bounds have you
ever gone like crazy on a football field
not only football field nobody cow so
for me this is you actually know part of
the story anyway but um on the field you
have discipline that governs how far you
can go normally for most people that you
have outliers like this situation and so
I just think there was a lot of
opportunities for miles Garrett just say
you know what I've gone too far I
probably need just need to stop now okay
I'll give you a few of them
hey the whistles the plays over balls
already gone I probably shouldn't tackle
him happens you go too far sometimes
okay now you try to pull his helmet off
okay you're pulling this helmet pulling
the helmet whistles blowing a ref you
saying stop that's probably what you
should have stopped that don't you
finally get their helmet off that's a
great place to stop you proved them
wrong you got the doggone helmet off now
you say you know what I told you I was
gonna beat you up you're a little
quarterback you're a whip
I'm gonna pull your helmet off and I
have it now my other thing is too is
like we live in this society especially
with like the ESPN 24/7 culture and here
at a place like bleacher report we're
like you can mean things and stuff where
if we have good video of you doing
something bad that clip probably got
played $21,000 now I want to say this
millions of times I am NOT defending
anybody right for me I'm just
voyeuristic I'm like man that was crazy
glad it wasn't me again hit and then I
look at it and and I also go man the
Browns played really well they play
really well and now they're screwed they
were part of that game were you saying
this is the best game that you've seen
Baker make field play the hardest part
too is all I wanted to talk about was
how [ __ ] awful Mason Rudolph was and
then if I said anything about Mason
Rudolph It was as if I was like victim
shaming and I was like I don't even care
about that last play he threw four
interceptions and it's clearly not the
quarterback of the future and the
Pittsburgh Steelers would want all these
games in a row if you had any chance
right and then the other thing I would
talk about was how Clete Blakeman ref
the read the game and they hit the under
again for the ninth straight time that
he's referee to game oh so I'm just
gonna let you know on Wesley's podcast
I'm gonna see which game cleats Ruffin
and we're gonna ride that train that's
right but that was wild Wow ending it
also as well because the timing of the
game games over everybody knows it
including probably miles Garrett the
game is over is done let's finish it
obviously you don't have to hit him with
the doggone helmet but I would think
that if miles Garrett had truce to him
he would say I kind of I was still
pissed off I kind of felt like the two
offensive linemen were attacking me and
I don't know what
quarterback was doing back there so I
swung my helmet and that's the guy I hit
with because he was the one running up
on me I think that's what he would say I
would be very well if you say they
blacked out I think in burr had a great
point and I tweeted this out and he may
have been talking about me where I was
like this is crazy I was like Garrett is
such a nice guy I've met him a few times
hung out with him a few times like he's
one of those new-age players that like
hangs out with like three or four kids
they talk about anime a lot yeah and I
tweeted out oh he does poetry this is
crazy and as Ingmar said he goes saying
that a guy does poetry and that means
he's a good guy he goes there's been a
lot of really bad people that have
written novels that's about poetry so I
agree could be both he could be both he
could be a great guy and the guy that
Black Dog blacked out on the football it
was just it was one of those moments for
me where I've never been in the
situation where I've gone I know the guy
and he's a good guy yeah and I've always
looked the people and been like like
Simmons used to do this with Ray Rice
because he was like dude I'm really good
friends with her a rice because they
both were in Jersey together and when
that happened he was just like dude he's
such a good guy and I was like he says
it doesn't matter we saw it on video
yeah now to be kind of in that position
but like I was in that position with
Darren Sharper which is crazy because
you know he went to William and Mary we
played we have Larry every single year I
played against him my freshman year in
college and you we worked you know in
the NFL you're always looking for you
know people that you kind of know and
then have some type of association with
and every time we played each other we
can always talk about one double-a
football the old days when he said Mary
I'm a Villanova and we've hung out a
couple of times I was out of football
and then obviously it [ __ ] man since
then went on that's what that's why the
whole argument of I know him he's a good
guy it's like immediately throw it out
because it's nonsense all right so
Kaepernick yeah
again a very multi-layered issue with so
many stories where we are as we're
recording this Monday at around 2:00 is
I guess the stories that came out this
morning was kind of jay-z coming out and
being like hey Kaepernick like why did
you make this into a stunt and it's it's
it's interesting because all week and I
still believe the NFL kind of set up
Kaepernick to make it really difficult
but I also can kind of see what they're
saying about like why did you reach out
to these NFL teams 30 minutes beforehand
and but it really it sounds like it
comes down to this waiver that
kaepernick didn't want to sign and the
NFL saying it's a typical waiver but it
sounds like Kaepernick's lawyers were
like there's a segment in here that if
you sign this you're not gonna be able
to sue for any collusion or anything
like that it's a really convoluted if
that's true NFL's did wrong and nobody
would have signed that especially given
what Kaepernick has been through for the
last three years if that's true and
again I haven't seen the contract but if
that or the waiver if that's true then
they're absolutely wrong in in you know
if you're Kaepernick you don't sign the
thing the biggest question that I have
for for Conor Kaepernick is this what
did you want to be done what did you
want from all this did you want to
actually want to play football if you
wanted to play football the best way to
do it unfortunately maybe against your
better judgment maybe against your
wishes wishes was to be able to find a
way to get in front of those 24 25
coaches in Atlanta Stadium and be able
to do it there that was the best way to
do it he was able to work out in front
of like 10 or 12 yeah let's not forget
that he didn't set this up and like the
time absolutely have they all set it up
for him I think it's interesting because
I appreciate that the fact that
Kaepernick has always been unabashedly
himself and he's never been like no I'm
not gonna just crumble right now to get
this shot I guess he looked good I don't
know how to evaluate quarterbacks
throwing on air yeah I think he still
got this here kitty-kitty so you still
have some zip on the ball ball placement
okay can you get the ball in these
windows which are wide open because
there's no one here in defense how is
your footwork look I think in those
situation you could kind of a little bit
see how I'm little of a shape ease in
yeah but I mean other than that
I'll just say this like there was a time
in the beginning of the year where I
thought the hardest part for Kaepernick
papinek was gonna be the issue that
every team in the NFL either seemingly
had their quarterback now or their
quarterback of the future because we've
had such an influx of rookie
quarterbacks these last few years we had
five two years ago three to like every
team seems to have one but then I
watched the games on Sunday Kyle Allen
doesn't look like the answer in Carroll
no Mitchell Cho Biscay does not look
like the answer in Chicago
Jameis Winston does not look like the
answer in Tampa Bay and so I mean in
Tennessee I guess you could say Ryan
Tannehill but I'm not doing all that but
there's a lot of teams where I go you
know mason rudolph the davis burg
steelers and we talked about the
possibilities denver and Brandon Allen
did play pretty well but I'm not saying
that but I guess the issue it is
interesting with Kaepernick because when
he does the postgame pressors has
stopped running from me then it kind of
has this tone where it's like I'm still
gonna be quote-unquote defiant that's
the part that literally that's the part
that if I'm an NFL team scares me away
and I'm not saying this right yeah it
didn't seem like he said give me a
chance we're gonna win it was stopped
running for me I can do it yeah and I
guess I could understand but at the same
point like if I was Kaepernick again if
we're gonna put ourselves into the the
mind of a human and this got thrown on
to you on a Tuesday and we got to sit
here and casually discuss it for five
days right we're I'm sure he was
frantically on the phone and trying to
figure things out for four or five days
calling it Hugh Jackson apparently was
like as soon as he found out just went
to the airport said screw it I'm out of
here so he clearly he was not invested
because Hugh definitely wants to get an
NFL coaching job so he's not gonna line
with Kaepernick like I'm sure that
Kaepernick felt kind of like stressed
out from the whole thing and then he
gets off the field and there's cameras
in his face so let's like also realize
what he was going through not only what
he's gone through for the last three
years I mean he feels I mean and and I
think that you could look it up and
research it
he probably legitimately feels that
there was a group of people the NFL
owners whoever whoever's in tars that
they don't want me here right they don't
want me involved with the NFL in why
would they now all of a sudden on the
Tuesday want to give me a chance
how real is this because to me the BS
meter goes really really high when I get
a call on Tuesday then you got to work
out on Saturday can I tell you what
might help us so I didn't like the story
that came out the day of on Saturday
that said the NFL is doing this because
some teams want to see how the public
reacts and I wanted to be late early
guys it's been three years we know how
the public's reacting stop using that
but my secret hope it was something that
Dan Patrick said that made me go home
that's interesting which was a lot of
teams when you bring in Kaepernick the
city begins to discuss it's the a block
of all the local news Colin Kaepernick
is in we surveyed the streets but if you
got rid of that initial stage by having
the work out there and they were they
were protected because there was 20 to
25 if the first thing that your fans had
was the signing yes then there was no
preliminary oh we have cold feet and I
was hoping that there were two or three
teams that were really really hoping and
they could use this to get a little bit
of cover so they can sign it and come
out with it right away I just really
believe that if an NFL owner came out
and said we we signed Colin Kaepernick
because we want to win a Super Bowl and
we believe this is gonna get there no
further questions
what is the let me ask you this and I
kind of lived through this in Philly
with Vic and the dogs yeah and there's
two different situations but I would you
gotta argue that Michael Vick I mean I'm
going to prison
right it's probably worse those sparked
fan outrage in terms of what they didn't
have to do all that to me before here's
the other part I think for calling in
and Vick got signed and he got something
the middle of the night that nobody knew
that's right and there was a bunch of
outrage but you know what Mike did and I
think I kind of talked about this to a
reporter the other day and credit to
Mike he went on a public media tour he
went to talk to kids he talked about his
experience and he did a great job of
kind of erasing the stigma of everything
that wouldn't happen
the problem with Collin and this this is
what I thought in my mind and I was just
kind of thinking of different things
maybe that there is actually a team that
went to the NFL was like listen we're in
a bad spot we're probably gonna need a
quarterback but we don't we just can't
sign them just you know on on Wednesday
we kind of got to go through the workout
process just to make it look legit and
all these other things how about you
just hold a workout for us we'll have
all the teams there we know we're gonna
sign them today this Monday which is
obviously talking from a week ago and in
in go cool and then all the nonsense
goes
on Saturday Collins to me the worst part
in my opinion and I think common
probably degraded to work out through
the ball well from the videos that I saw
the post post workout press conference
was the issue in my opinion because now
you you're going back to three years ago
yeah you're fighting the battle again
now the team was like I kind of thought
that was squash and we would have
definitely made that move maybe maybe
we're not quite to that point yet I
guess my thing is to and this is kind of
how I'm gonna wrap it up is I'm seeing a
lot of people putting all of this on
Colin no it's not only like there's
they're saying that you don't want to
sign in Colin because of all the drama
he brings and I want to go dear let's
say boomer esiason who I watched on TV
just absolutely destroy Colin Kaepernick
because okay boomer like his name fits
perfectly but they act as though Colin's
the one bringing all the drama like the
media plays a huge role in this the NFL
plays a huge role in this this has now
become an ecosystem and it's become
something that everyone is throwing
pieces into so to blame all of this on
Colin is ridiculous that's crazy like a
lot of it is the older guys on
television that are usually white that
are putting all of this at his feet and
saying he's always he's the distraction
and what we've learned is that like we
create these systems of of just anger
and then we put it back on the person
yes and it's and especially someone like
when you really look at all the things
that Colin has said over the time like
he was right no he's about the collusion
got paid for it absolutely so so like
you should look back at all that and go
so who was the crazy side and here's a
guy that got paid cuz he was right or
all the people on TV saying it was
[ __ ] in his original on TV never
have to pay for when they [ __ ] get
everybody Hank his original point was
right - there is social injustice yes
there is police brutality to a specific
group of people so what he was standing
up for in the beginning and also like
was absolutely right we have the guy
that like if you were to look at the two
people that were the biggest part of
this cause it was Colin capper
and Eric Reid and Eric Reid got signed
by the Panthers and has been playing
football for two three years and his
stances haven't changed he still talks
about it in postgame press conferences
he's still Neil sometimes and I never
hear people talking about it so it
clearly hasn't thrown off the Panthers
so it's just if a team's gonna sign them
I hope it happened well here's the other
part I just I always get mad at the
media and I'll end it here I think that
if you were interested in signing Colin
what better chance than this opportunity
right now you saw that he still has the
arm you saw that he's still in shape you
still saw that he still had has the
desire to play now if I'm the owner I'm
gonna come in and say all right Connor
we wanna we want to sign you you know
here's the things that I see as far as
your situation was bad we hated what
would happen we've respect you as a
person we respect your rights we also
respect the things that you stick up for
because that's important to us too but
we have a every team has social social
media also has community stuff every
single team has that so you know what
Colin you can help us in that way to not
just want to feel but you can help us
all to feel - we're gonna sign you
because you're gonna make our team
better at the end of the day that's the
real question does he make your team
better will we saw from Mason Rudolph
the other night can Colin Kaepernick do
better s I I guess who couldn't bro that
was so bad you run around and make it
first down if you could do that then
that's better than what you saw from
Mason and another six or seven
quarterbacks that played yesterday I'm
kind of hoping the Ravens sign them cuz
there's such like America's team right
now that it would feel really I kind of
you know as I'm talking about Pittsburgh
who better than Mike Tom and I would
love I know that's how I said last week
that was my number one team for Thursday
Night Football
all right that's enough Carol - I would
like that let's talk about Bengal tank /
dolphin tank are you ready to buy stuff
let's go it's purchasing time welcome
back to another edition of Bengal tank
formerly dolphin Tech which is a parody
of the TV show shark tank which is a
subsidiary of the Japanese program
Dragons Den which itself was originally
Tigers of money and a Bengal is of
course a subspecies of tiger
it all comes full circle the reason you
tune into the left go show animal bags
first into the tank left goes looking
for an investment partner to help tweak
one specific aspect of watching NFL
games in 2019 and by tweak we mean burn
it to the ground and bury the ashes so
we never have to think about it again
one if that's true about den and all
that stuff yeah that's that's pretty
cool yeah that's incredible incre it
just shows you that there is no original
there is nothing new that's gonna be
made in our and that everything is
stolen from somewhere else and nothing
good happens in America anymore anyway
there is something happening on Sundays
that needs to be stopped it is ruining
the sanctity of the game it is
destroying fun it causes people watching
football to look at their friends and go
why are we even doing this and I want to
abolish it from the sport it is new it
is recent and it needs to be sent out to
the ocean in a Viking funeral and set
ablaze never be heard from again
do you buy the abolishing of this thing
is that it yes questions you're an
investor okay fair shirt capitalist
Brian Westbrook how does this thing
connect the game it caught it it makes
it feel like wrestling it makes it feel
as though we are watching things at home
that we know not to be true and yet they
continue to do it and they laugh in our
face and they mock us as though worse
[ __ ] stupid right and we're not and
this can happen to the offense and the
defense in okay so you know it so just I
can't get some mystical state it
involves the referee yeah no it's I am
buying the fact that we have to figure
out something better than our current
system because we're the ones at replays
replays I was talking about the coin
toss I think it's completely arbitrary I
think I think we're going to replay that
we no way with DeAndre Hopkins yes
should be put on a videotape
and it should be sent in to roger
goodell with a letter that says either
al river on goes or this [ __ ] rule
goes because either he like he is making
a mockery and it is not enjoyable I am
watching the game let's just say from my
gambling perspective right I took the
over in the first half of 24 cuz I did
yes this is a person who that's seven
points Brian Westbrook that is blatant
that was blatant pass interference and
now I'm sitting there the entire game
going how much different would this game
been if instead of going and not scoring
for the first three quarters the Texans
were up 7-nothing to start the game how
different would that game have been it
changes the entire game completely
different and it was blatant and so you
either need to get rid of the rule
because it was therefore blatant
examples of pass interfere no wasn't
that's not the case it no I have to
think in theory it was therefore that
mostly it was there for situations in
the playoffs that could change the
course of who's gonna win a lose a game
okay okay so that's what it really said
that I have a bigger issue okay if that
call against the Andre Hopkins is not
made but they start flipping pies in the
playoffs then what the [ __ ] did I watch
for 16 weeks garbage
you can watch the anymore thing is is I
should that my response should not have
to be coaches stop challenging pass
interference because it's just a waste
of your time because at the same point
coaches this is the reason we put it in
there are some pass interferences where
I understand there's hand fighting its
back and I get it right but when Marlon
Humphries commits pass interference
three different times on one play the
pull of a jersey the tackle and then the
hit in the face and the spin like that's
what I've always really is the reason
I've always heard the reason you call
these you need to Spanier I got the spin
mm-hmm get everything al river on mm-hmm
I need you at a podium and I need you to
explain the process
I need transparency on this I don't need
an email I don't need a tweet
I don't need Times New Roman 12
paragraph I need you at a podium going
here is what we do when a P I challenge
comes in and here's the reason it's
getting changed at a clip of 0.07%
because that was blatant and to be
honest it's disrespectful because
football fans are not stupid and the
gambling football fan is really not
stupid and now you're messing with money
billions of dollars and I already know
you got a few referees that the unders
hitting at a hundred percent mm-hmm and
we got some referees that are calling
hands to the face and changing League
and so now you're giving the humans more
power and guess who I don't want to have
power who's that
the referee humans especially the ones
in New York get it out of here bro well
they're trying to figure this that was
cathartic yeah I see you're excited
about that because I can tell you may
have lost a dollar or two I lost the
money or money or two on this whole deal
Justin Tucker missed his first field
goal I think that you're absolutely
right I think that they've made a
mockery of the system that what they
said they were trying to do they're not
even close to achieving that which is
sad because that you're saying listen
this is a simple thing to do and we can
tell whether you have two feet down we
can tell that that's easy we can see
that on replay we also can tell very
easily with pass interference is very
very easily offensive ly and defensively
and the NFL has chosen to they ignore it
again because they came out from the
beginning they would have just came out
and said listen we're not gonna allow
what happened to the Saints to happen
ever again and if it happens in the
playoffs we'll make sure it's the right
call then everybody knows even playing
field everybody knows but in this case
they said we're gonna do it all season
long and we have practice of going to it
you know just imagine if you're a coach
you've got all of the challenges wrong
all season long now it's your playoff
game what are you gonna do not throw it
if it's a critical will you do I guess
my I need a timeout or I need a
challenge that's called that they never
change what's really interesting is
that's what they would have called that
if they would have reversed that with
DeAndre Hopkins yesterday
would have been a part of me that would
have said I know that they haven't been
flipping them all year but that was the
example that was blatant got it right
that I would have gone you know what
they were saving it for the most blatant
mm-hmm but that was the most blatant and
they didn't do it
and now I'm just sitting here going just
I don't need to waste eight minutes of
every game with this charade anymore and
it's annoying well it is annoying
annoying is it's shameful it also makes
our game like Oh Don because you brought
up a good point the betting aspect
especially in America billions of
dollars on the line and that was one of
the most bad games what if what if
there's a bunch of money on the line for
betters obviously there is vested
interest for players for coaches have
been in the dog one facility all week
long putting in 20 hours a week artists
and we're getting the people that are
part-time yes have make the decision the
other part is what if this game was the
one game that decided Houston's playoff
ability right what if it was it maybe I
don't know we know we don't know how to
seasonally don't know how this game it
is but in the same way that you're
talking about we don't want playoff
games to be determined by a bad calls
well what if they just determine in the
week eleven of the season look look at
Detroit sad Detroit was playing very
very well earlier this season they went
and they beat the Eagles they went and
surprised some other teams I mean they
they took Kansas City to the brink they
go to a buy at 2-1 in one and they're
feeling pretty good they are beating the
Packers and then there are those calls
against the guy they took from the
Patriots whose name I can't remember the
illegal hands to the face they lose that
Packers game and then they go Thank You
Trey flowers and then they go on to lose
five of the next six and if they would
have won that game who knows threes
important of the team and that's the
thing is there's 16 games yeah the
sample size is so small yeah one loss is
enormous it could prevent you from
making the pass that's my point
absolutely my point all right let's get
back to Bengal tank I need to calm down
next into the tank a surprise candidate
has emerged in the tightly contested MVP
race he is talented his team is winning
and above all he's one of the greatest
defensive players in the NFL just
kidding that entire side of the ball has
literally no chance of winning MVP he's
a quarterback it's it's the first time
in a few years where I feel like the MVP
race is one that people actually like we
talked about it a lot last year where
mahomes versus Brees was the up and back
the entire time but really after week
eleven it was mahomes award even though
all of New Orleans really didn't like me
because I kept saying it was my homes
but right now I feel like people are
loving this one because there's a few
legitimate candidates this is a
candidate that I don't think has been
brought up a lot I believe right now he
is either the third or fourth best
candidate it is not Russell Wilson it is
lot Lamar Jackson those are my top two
but this is a guy that is a quarterback
that I believe has a legitimate case and
he can take his team to the playoffs and
I think for the first time he's been the
one leading the way first time in his
career the first time were it's like
clearly him yeah yeah okay so ask all
the questions you quarterbacks playing
well first time leading his team in a
way he's right
how many tell I mean how many games of
the team one team is winning leading
their division he's top seven in
quarterback ratings what would I buy him
as a legitimate contender for us yeah
for what for it for MVP I think you'll
agree with me I had a phenomenal
touchdown interception ratio 21:09 okay
my TP in terms of like yards per pass
right
he's right up there core to - okay I
think that as far as the MVP case that
we I think we already know who's gonna
end up winning between Lamar and Russell
and it's gonna be hard for anybody else
to get into that just based on we're in
where we're at there to see this guy is
also leading the NFL and passing yards I
like that I mean it's number one oh I'll
buy a quarterback that's doing that
absolutely
dak Prescott about absolutely by dak
Prescott and here's a for a couple
reasons why I love I've seen that he's
matured and I'm not talking about just
mature things he say he's always been
the face of the franchise
a great leader we've always yes have
seen that I think the guys in the locker
don't speak volumes too bad but I think
as a quarterback matures they understand
defense is better they see where the
blitzes are coming from they understand
where they have coverages that where
they could throw one on one to michael
gallop down the football field they
understand the blitzes are coming from
the right side I need to work to the
left side they're changing the place
underneath Center and most importantly
that Dallas team was built to run the
football teams were stopping the run by
putting eight nine guys in the box and
now you dak had an opportunity I'm
talking about the past not not as much
this season he had an opportunity to
throw the ball a little bit more now
teams aren't doing that anymore they
were doing that at 28 29 presenting at a
time at a clip eight nine guys in a box
now they're just saying okay 15 percent
of the time we're gonna pick eight guys
in the box I try to stop Zeke but really
we're trying to stop dak now and so
teams aren't solely saying we're gonna
let you run the football you know we
were try to stop the running throw the
football no now they're saying we're
trying to stop your passes and dak is
still exploding down a football field
finding guys that are open he has
single-handedly made Michael gallop into
a very good player Michael Gavin I
thought they they developed a
relationship last year during a
pre-season never really you know
developed throughout the season he had a
knee scoped gals was on a roll this year
and then he had the nice right and then
he came back but thinking about this
tech leads the NFL in passing urine
never would've thought that would have
happened 32:21 already touchdown
interception ratio 21 to 19 thing
quarterback rating of a hundred and four
point one I look at dak right now and I
know the first thing is let's get
perspective just like everybody was
going oh s--- and Arnold's back and I
went hey guys it was against the
Washington Redskins like just like they
were like oh wow here comes Jimmy
grandpa I was like okay that was against
the Arizona Cardinals
let's also remind ourselves that Detroit
has won the worst past defenses the NFL
30 which is fine at the same point
let's also factor in that Zeke is still
got playing like using cabo Amari Cooper
is bare
he's planning to have the snare he's
hurt Jason Witten is not a real receiver
he lost some offensive line before the
game and Dallas's defense has been
abysmal turn you led up 27 points to
Jeff Driskel and beau Scarborough you
let up 28 to Minnesota dak has had to
carry this team by himself and and I
look at Dallas and I go look there it's
gonna get a lot harder at New England
home against Buffalo in a short week at
Chicago home against the Rams at Philly
we're gonna learn a lot but I'm gonna
say this what we're seeing out of dak is
30 million dollars a year 30 I'm saying
it's Lee saying I'm saying well he was
going to get 30 before the season I'm
saying let's list the quarterbacks that
we believe are better than dak right now
okay okay I think that's a fairer to
pick pull up the teams
okay let me go you start with Patrick
mahomes of course Patrick moams is
better than dak Russell Wilson he's
better than deck I would still put Aaron
Rodgers to have to put drew drew brees I
lose close I would put dak ahead of Drew
Brees Matt Ryan I would put dak ahead of
Matt Ryan
deshaun Watson I would put I think I'll
put deshaun Watson ahead of deck carson
wentz I would put dak ahead of Carson
Wentz what about Jimmy G dak okay Lamar
we are you go over Lamar yes okay I mean
I don't know if there's anybody left
those are the were cousins maybe no yeah
I would not put Kurt cousins over attack
oh yeah I think I would make like two
guys I think I would have dak as my
fifth best quarterback in the NFL right
now yeah because he's now better than a
home Lamar Russell or DeSean okay I have
him below them really but I don't know
who else is ahead of them
I think jack is my fifth best
quarterback in the I think you can make
that argument I would all he's got more
like I watched my watch Drew Brees
against the Bucs it was all chimera and
Thomas what he's owed me drew Brees
that's the older generation yeah but I'm
comparing to a
but yeah he's not he's not better I
watched Tom Brady know in the colon 2
comma DeLeon - yeah yeah I mean Matt
Stafford is out he's not playing right
now - yes I was playing as a play but
he's not there right now
well knocking - bring back the ghost of
Ben Roethlisberger no he's better than
Jamie's better than Jared golf he's
better than he is better than Carson
winds top there's no doubt about he's a
top 5 chord but just no doubt yeah the
way that he's playing right now yeah he
has command of this football team
now don't forget he has a brand new
offensive coordinator and quarterback
coach - so he's dealing with some some
changes as well I love he's been
impressive I love when players bet on
themselves
hey and then the team sitting there
going we're excited that we have to pay
you because it means that you're playing
great but damn it imagine that
conversation now after Jerry Jones like
man I could have got away Jerry Jerry's
going going hey guys we got the Patriots
the bills the buyers - right he's gonna
have to pay that's not negotiate 39 yeah
if I'm if I'm them I'm hitting up DAC in
between week 16 and 72 late play watch
too late but soon right now yeah you
know why it's too late because now once
you get to the middle part of the season
I'm coasting Andy's playing well he
there's nothing that you can tell me I'm
betting on myself all right we got one
more one more Bengal tank for you Brian
Westbrook so you're two buys today let's
see if you buy a third and finally let
go believes there's one top echelon AFC
team that won't make the playoffs
they've got a lot of talent but
unfortunately they've got an arrow
heading downward
and let go believes they'll be watching
the postseason from the comfort of their
own homes perhaps they should just end
the season and we can put them out of
their misery Kansas City is in the state
of Missouri I have a team that is
currently in the playoffs I have a team
that I believe will be on the outside
looking in in the AFC Ungar and they're
a team with an up-and-coming top four
quarterback that I believe it's just not
setting up pretty for them okay can they
run the football
yes do they have a good defense average
average defense is there coach does he
have winning pedigree what do you mean
has he won I'm gonna hate their coach
you hate their coach hate their coach
Wow
hate their coach yeah you hate him you
know who I'm talking I know are they in
the AFC South yeah they are okay
damn it twenty-one questions yeah yeah
all right you have to guess now the
Texans yeah yeah I think I don't think
they're making the [ __ ] playoffs you
know I want to say this trying to think
of it they do have three straight home
games and it's gonna be home against the
Colts this Thursday night home against
the Patriots on ten days yeah and then
home against the Broncos but Bill
O'Brien never beats the Patriots
seemingly and my thing is this is when
you look at the standings in the AFC and
you see how the Colts are when Jacoby
Brissette is back and that offensive
line is to different like that against
Jacksonville now Marlin Mack broke his
hand it's gonna be tough I don't see the
Texans winning the division and the fact
that t:y Hilton could be playing on
Thursday I think they're gonna be in
trouble and then you look at the wild
cards Buffalo now moves to seven and
three that schedule is easy I've been
saying it since week four that Buffalo
was getting a wild card I have you can
check the tape and I look at Oakland
right now and how they're kind of
clicking Houston is gonna be on the
outside looking in I know what I think
Houston makes up and I'll tell you why
oh did
I I don't know if you bought the take
well I will I'll buy you saying that
they're out I think the Texans are not
so don't buy it no I'm not buying no
because you can't tell me that they have
a top five quarterback deshaun Watson
and he can make people walk on water
that can't even swim and now you're
telling me that they're not gonna make
the playoffs
is my is my ninth best quarterback Derek
Carr has played played great this year
the radar similar to we before because
that's really what my take is is that I
believe that the bills are gonna lock up
one of these wild card spots now I do
believe in the bills like that I mean
are you I think it's a schedule type of
thing they get the big at the Denver
Broncos a West Coast team at home and a
one o'clock game they building sort of
Rob you still have a game with the Jets
I understand it they got the Steelers
coming up a little bit later and they
stink
I I just I look at the bills the fact
that they already have seven wins I go
that team's gonna get to ten and then I
look at the Houston Texans and go well
guess what they still play the Patriots
huh they also get the cults and I
granted they have two games against the
Titans but I just I don't buy the Texans
so out of the next six game the Texans
really need to get to ten which is a
number they need to win four out of the
next six right and you don't think they
can do it listen I think the Shaun
Watson is a special enough player and
the Raiders get the Jets the Broncos
yeah it'll be it'll be it'll go down to
the last week for this thing and I'm
just saying that of all the teams in the
coaches don't have to keep winning so
let's start there they have to keep
winning six or four as well same thing
is the Texans they have to keep winning
- so right this is assuming that I I do
not believe the Texans are going to win
it could it be possibly because you just
saw him against the best team in
football against the Ravens I mean
because the Ravens let me just say
they're the best team in football right
now well you would agree with that
you mean we would agree to remember
early on it takes too much trying to
sing about tomorrow even listen I can I
can I can be honest enough to be
objective and say the the best team in
football right now is the Ravens their
defense has balled out oh it's been so
they the secondary is Benson
we've got nacchan Walser they got back
they got Peter rushing the passer like
nobody's business because they're
holding people up on the other side I
don't think that was just the Ravens
defense I also think the Texans
offensive line is still not that good
they're crazy and they gave up all those
pics with Tunsil and they can't protect
the quarterback that and but this is all
of my argument against the Texans and I
also think that Texans secondary is
really really poor they're starting a
rookie and Lonnie Johnson who's getting
destroyed they really don't have a pass
rush anymore because they don't have
clowny they don't have lot mercilessness
by himself
I like TJ I don't think they are the
pieces they don't have a good kicker
they have a coach that crumbles have
he's in a deficit I look at the Raiders
they're getting a pass rush this kid max
Williams is coming along at four sets
yeah like no crosby max cracks across me
he's been great they've been able to
pound the rock and that passing offense
has been good there's things to build
around there in Oakland
I look at Indianapolis and I go man you
can lose Marlon Mac here's a question
'van Williams comes in and he's another
hundred yard rusher they did that
without T Y Hilton I have reasons for
confidence and I have reasons to sell
the Texans right now well first of all
Indianapolis they played the
Jacksonville Jaguars and they're ready
to quit Nick Foles made no difference in
that football he looked pretty good
earlier it's just a culture one of those
teams that this is the time of the year
when everyone's gonna be like we have to
face that offensive line yeah right
they're big
who do you trust more at the quarterback
position Derek Carr
deshaun Watson deshaun Watson of course
right so would you agree there yeah but
I would take every other part of the
Raiders right okay so they play the
Colts that's a tough one for the text
like Derek Carr doesn't lose you games
he doesn't deshaun Watson can win you
gangster so Patriots I think the Eric
Carr does have to overcome his own coach
I think they got a chance to beaten the
Patriots in in Houston quite honestly
you want to bet on it what a better
money oh so you're gonna hate the Texans
to beat the Patriots in Houston yes
all right how much was that of money 1 1
of money of course that Rocko's it was
amazing at home I mean they got a chance
I see three wins right here Texans
Titans Buccaneers and Titans that's
three wins
you just said four teams well I meant to
say Titans here so that's three
three wins Titans but I'll bet you I'll
bet you another money that the Texans
don't make the playoffs
deshaun Watson don't this is what we
need to bet on because you're a big
Texans guy like the Texans the whole lot
I like the charm watching I like the way
the Carlos Hyde runs the football
obviously the receivers if we can get
all of them healthy short at one time
would be great but at some point the
defense is gonna have to show up and
play out a little bit the Ravens did not
punt or commit a turnover yesterday the
Ravens have they have something in their
DNA and I know what it is that other
team just can't solve right now first of
all there's two things John Harbaugh is
the best coach in the NFL at situation
of football understanding the
circumstances understanding the rules I
was third in ten and let's say it's four
from ten with the wins against us we
might as well go for it if we were the
difference between punting and and going
for it is so small we might just weird
stuff that's the way he thinks that's
what we saw when he was in fillable
defender Philadelphia so he's the best
in the league of situational football
that's one thing you have a riddle at
offense that no one can figure out they
have three players right now in the top
ten in yards per carry Lamar Jackson
Mark Ingram and Gus Edwards you can't
figure it out you don't know who has the
ball and at any time when you have the
quarterback making a decision your
defense can't be right and I will tell
you right now defensive players in the
league are not disciplined enough to
understand okay I'm gonna stay here and
not run over there and try to make a
play there's just not disciplined enough
and you can't find that discipline in a
week's time before you play this team so
that's two things right there
Lamar Jackson's playing out of his mind
we understand that yes lastly their
defense in the last couple weeks three
weeks how about how long as Marcus
Peters been there month yeah has turned
the corner Jimmy Smith came back
Marcus Peter Humphrey was already
playing well Earl Thomas is just kind of
in a weird way just hanging on just
doing this thing make it sound a place
and that defensive line now is playing
at a different level hard to beat the
last three games they have beaten
Russell Wilson and the Seahawks who have
eight wins the New England Patriots who
have nine and the Houston Texas to have
seven wins by a combined 65 points hmm
they made a laugher of the Patriots they
made a laugher the Seahawks and they
made a laugher the
it is what are you gonna say well I
wouldn't so so I know the scores matter
the Patriots and the Seahawks both had a
chance to win those games yes they could
have done it absolutely but we have not
seen the Patriots play like that at all
I look at the Ravens and you start to go
because I I know that every year there
are these little stretches where teams
go through highs yeah where the Niners
were the team from weeks three through
six
the Ravens right now have been the it
team through weeks nine through twelve
some team will solve them this will not
continue to people that are saying that
the Ravens are unbeatable or unsolvable
someone will beat them somebody will
solve them it happens every year yes the
key is who will be the team that goes
into the playoffs on the high but when I
look at the Ravens I go phenomenal
coaching staff OC DC amazing great
special teams best kicker in the NFL
phenomenal old line solid D line good
pass rush great secondary can play man
or zone three running backs that are
dangerous in Ingram Edwards and Hill
wide receivers that I think are low key
scary in Hollywood Brown Willie Snead
and Seth Roberts and I'm not Jews is the
best but then you have three tight ends
in Andrews Boyle and another guy who I
can't even remember and it hurts Hayden
Hurst who was a first-round pick the
thing that the Ravens are doing that so
great is they play you in these heavy
formations and you have no idea what
they're doing
you have no idea if they're running you
have no idea if they're passed right
they could put three tight ends out
there and it could be a power formation
and if you don't load up
well then Mark Ingram who's the most
aggressive runner and the NFL's gonna
pound you in the face oh you do well
Hayden Hurst and Mark Andrews and Mark
Ingram and and Hollywood at Brown we're
gonna throw them all out there right and
so it really is you need to be ready for
everything and and the teams that have
been able to beat the Ravens this year
were teams that jumped ahead of them in
the scoring and they couldn't and force
them to become a passing team Kansas
City jumped out to a lead the Ravens had
to abandon the run Cleveland jumped out
to a lead
the Ravens had to abandon the run now in
both of those games
the Ravens really had a chance when you
go back and look but the way that you
beat the Ravens is you make them
one-dimensional by jumping out to a lead
and I would beg the Ravens even if
you're down 14 don't abandon the run I
think it's hard to me it's hard to do
that because their defense is playing
better now laying phenomenal compared to
I also think it's hard to do that now
because Lamar Jackson seems to be a very
competent passer at this point I mean
he's making some throws they don't they
don't look like you know over hand over
the top old school quarterback throws
because he's throwing his sidearm but
he's making some accurate throws some
throws over the over the the defenders
ear hole to the tight end wide open in
the end zone
great touch passes he knows where you we
talked about it with deck know where you
want the ball to go and get it there be
accurate he does exactly that and then
you add the running which you know that
makes them a different player you're
gonna hear this from a lot of fans and
from a lot of analysts Lamar is going to
get hurt and I get it because here's the
truth no no no here's the truth
watch watches runs they don't know but
here's the truth it's going to happen
okay everybody but this is like telling
somebody during the Vick era oh it's not
gonna last or like somebody in the
McNabb era it's not gonna last right
okay it's the same thing with Steph
Curry oh he's gonna get hurt they will
but [ __ ] enjoy it there is gonna be a
two three-year window of this Lamar and
then he is likely be given him more of a
pocket passer he's not going to run as
much and it's gonna change but my thing
is instead of saying oh he's not gonna
be this guy forever enjoy this we are
got we are in the window so I please
this is like me eating a steak and
saying up you're not gonna like me
eating a really nice meal and you saying
up you're gonna regret that tomorrow huh
fine let me enjoy it but I want to enjoy
it now I really don't like this thing
with Lamar everyone's like three years
from now he's not gonna be this mobile
dude if you want to be that guy be that
guy but if you are not enjoying Lamar
right now if the NFL has told you
anything and it's not for long
savor these moments this is like when
Steph Curry was at his prime
and you have and it changed defenses
because anywhere he went you had to be
why is Lamar doing better passing
because when he moves out of the pocket
everyone goes red alert run and we got
man-to-man and Lamar's hittin those
throws so please don't be that guy don't
be that friend that goes it might not
last enjoy
Lamar enjoy because this is it guys we
will never see this again it is
beautiful it needs to be behold because
I said it so don't be that guy I said it
last week as well you have to reset the
notion of I need a pocket passer for
10-12 years maybe you just need a guy
that can get you five six years of
excellent football that nobody can stop
and maybe that's Lamar Jackson maybe in
Hoonah who knows what happened we saw
the jump between his first year in his
second year as far as a passer he's a
much better passer he's as much but he's
a smarter player at this point as well
and so maybe the jump between his second
and third year is is just as big I
wouldn't want to challenge you just a
little bit ok the injury side thing I
watched all his runs I went back and
watched him I watched him yesterday went
back and watched him today
look where he's getting hit at though by
secondary guy yes all the big hits and I
got a hurt on it was my D lineman
sometimes about linebackers but a lot of
time is just a D lineman fall annoying
yeah all of their 350 pounds body weight
he's getting hit by corners that are
probably smaller than him say these that
are slightly bigger than him he's not
getting punished in the pocket they're
not getting good angles on him
conversely look at the punishment that
deshaun Watson took yesterday he wants
to throw the ball from the pocket he's
gonna get killed in that pocket in and
he took some net like been backwards his
knees stuck underneath guys he took some
bad shots yesterday so I mean just as
much as we're talking about being a
pocket passer you know you'd be able to
be good bah blah blah well DeSean
Jackson - on Watson's not gonna last for
long if he gets keep getting hit the way
that he was yesterday that you say that
because there is this this this group of
quarterbacks that it's the Carson Wentz
Jameis Winston DeSean Watson's where
they've been amazing an escape ability
and where a lot of it is I have a
defensive lineman on my shoulder pad
I'm strong enough and elusive enough to
kind of dip out right and that's the
scariest one because that's when you
have a 320 pounder holding you and when
you pull your muscles are not ready to
handle that extra weight and that's when
something happens and and Lamar is much
more in the Russell Wilson Cuyler Murray
mode which is his first Quick Step has
been so good I'm not even seeing
defensive lineman getting a hand on it
okay touch him because I get afraid when
a guy like Lamar has a hand on him and
he goes I can escape anything and what I
really want him to do is those are the
ones I want you to go down because
that's when I watch you pull something
but I don't want to say any of that
because the true thing is is Lamar has
been an absolute joy if it's a joy to
watch and he's joy he's made the NBP
race which yeah you mentioned it earlier
years it was kind of an MEP whatever
we'll get to it but this year is made it
interesting to figure out Russell still
rust or is it okay because my thing is I
knew that this would be a big Lamar MVP
push week as it should Russell Wilson is
on a bye that's right and so it's what
have you done for me lately Lamar puts
up 41 and he does everything I get it I
believe though that we've seen the
Ravens defense come out of nowhere and
add value and pick sixes and all that
and I'm seeing Russell Wilson's defense
still stink yeah and like I watched that
Niners game I still can't get that game
out of my head we're like Russell Wilson
is still making game saving plays and I
think that he has added more value to
his team I would also say that what we
saw last weekend Christian McCaffrey is
officially out of the race and the
reason is this he still puts up a
hundred and seventy total yards he still
has an incredible day and it doesn't
change the fact that they lose by 25
Dalvin cook had a very below average
game I think he it was like not even a
yard per carry and then it was all Kirk
Cousins but it is Lamar it is Russell
we're gonna watch my homes that were
recording this before I was gonna put on
the show to put on the show put a put on
the show and dak is out there for me and
I think Aaron Rodgers that's my top five
unfortunately they're all quarterback
you know what's we are as we think about
this
Ravens team as this is a team that just
loved my my Baltimore Ravens there built
your Baltimore Ravens they're built they
complement each other right and so
defense gets the ball back
Lamar runs it and does this I mean
there's not a lot of teams will use
Kansas City for example obviously their
defense stinks but they can't compliment
each other because they score so fast on
offense the defense gives it up so fast
that they get this it's kind of weird
the defense stays on the field this
defense where the Ravens compliments his
offense perfectly office obviously
complements the defense they stay on the
field they're running the football yeah
running the clock down defenses
opportunities this is all that part the
one thing that sim said to me that has
stayed with me for a long time I think
was a his quote from his dad which was
fast teams get slower big teams don't
get smaller and we're at the time of the
year where all those fast guys sorry we
don't hear from anymore there's a reason
that Shaun Jackson's don't play that
many games and T Y Hilton misses a lot
of games at this point of the year you
start to slow down but teams that are
like the Ravens where they got eight
deep at their D line yeah seven deep on
their own I heard nasty strong that's
why I have faith in the Colts because
it's at this point of the year where man
that speed rush isn't so speedy anymore
it's about holding up the GATS it's the
reason the Patriots always win because
they're not really collecting the fast
guys know they're always bigger than
their opponents and and that's why I
look at this Ravens team they were
always built for the long haul they were
always built to lean on you they Brandon
Williams Brandon Williams got paid a
boatload from Baltimore most fans don't
know who he is but offensive linemen
know who he is because he's to gap in
the whole thing looking game nasty yeah
intimidating the coach try to get a Oh
Byron Nelson the touchdown yesterday
couldn't quit now Byron that's quitting
Nelson touched down yesterday guard so
I'm gonna humble brag a little bit I
texted Quinton huh and I said bro
kegstand was amazing yes and true fans
love cochon oh he responded with thanks
man because there's a Jim Irsay quote
when Quinton Nelson got after he goes
hey Quinton what's up man
and so quit Nelson you are the man I
wish they gave him that touchdown and
that is quit Nelson to a tee whoever was
the offensive lineman that scored a
touchdown we were all doing it
quit Nelson's the ultimate team place
what's up let's go now to the interview
with Gronk he's got a big announcement
and and we brought in pat pat and i'm
telling you i have never heard Grunk
laugh this hardly it is that good I also
asked him who you takin kelsier Kittel I
also asked him well question extra yeah
I'll tell you his answer after the
interview and then Pat Pat asked him the
big question are you coming back here's
the interview with Rob Gronkowski
Roberto are you there what's up man ah
dude when I heard that the Super Bowl
was in Miami I thought there are very
few people that can throw together a
party worthy of my attendance and the
incredible energy of Miami Beach and
then I heard of Gronk Beach Saturday
before the Super Ball and I need to know
what is there gonna be any sand left
when you're done with it is there gonna
be any sand laughs I don't know man
there could be a sand storm while we're
there you know we're gonna be ripping up
the dance moves so I don't know we might
be going creating another ocean no I
love it
so just so the reason that we're able to
talk to you today is the greatest Madlib
I've ever read when I heard Gronk is
having a party it could have been Gronk
is having a party at blank with blank
and blank sponsored by blank and I would
have guessed Miami
with Rick Ross and FlowRider sponsored
by Monster Energy how excited are you
what is the vibe gonna be what can
people do to actually attend oh man
help me I'm actually super excited about
this cuz you know I believe a balanced
life man
you gotta work hard yeah but also you
got to enjoy yourself you got to live
life to the fullest you got a you know I
always say this just lose your mind and
I I don't know exactly if everyone knows
what that means what lose your mind
meeting how'd it do a festival have it
to a party and just enjoying yourself
route goings free dancing just not think
have a care in the world at those
and that that's what's going to be all
about I'm coming to enjoy yourself all
in a positive fun way that's what we're
looking for we're looking for everyone
to come you know with the mindset that
this play this is going to be fun this
is going to be positive where it's going
to be wild on top of it and it's just
going to be a blast and you're going to
just lose your mind and always and we
want to make it one of the most epic
beach parties ever I'm not just in the
history of the Super Bowl but in the
history of Miami Wow you know no and no
one knows the Super Bowl weekend like me
I know it I know it tremendously well I
played in this like five times I've been
there on all the other times and it just
needs a party like this man I mean I
thought other parties are cool but we
need a party like this where I like
bumping that'd be crazy and everyone's
going to be enjoying it and I mean it's
good and I'm the beauty my very own
music festival here and it's constructed
right understands of Miami Beach with Ag
and I'm bringing all my favorite artists
food drinks and beats performers and
some in some of the artists I mean just
mind-blowing
featuring Diplo okay Rick Ross okay
twice lowrider ooh
hey baby I love it I love it after this
weekend they're gonna call you mr. 305
okay I have a special guest I have I
have a co-worker his name is pat pat his
name is pat pat cuz he is from
Summerville he is a huge Patriots fan he
is shaking it his knees to ask you this
question so I'm gonna turn it over to
Pat Pat what's up Gronk it's pat pat the
number one fan of the number one team in
the known sports universe the New
England Patriots
you're my favorite player of all time
and the picture of you and Tom Brady
lovingly wrestling at Fenway PAC is the
poster on my bedroom wall my bathroom
wall and the windshield of my car it's
not safe but it's totally worth it so I
can look upon your face when I'm stuck
in traffic on Route 128 anyway I got one
quick question for you Gronk and it
comes in four parts part one well you
consider coming back to the team part
two
won't you please come back part three
are you aware that by coming back you
would make me and my seven roommates the
happiest three-bedroom apartment in all
of Austin pad for not really a question
more of a statement please come back
thanks Croc and I'll take my answer off
the
but Phaedra man you are fat what was the
name again I you gotta be happy Pat hi
Pat oh my god that was epic man that was
unbelievable I mean if I'm allowed to go
to this party and stroll into the
Superbowl game well you know you know if
I can make it to the game in McDade and
then maybe I'll still be able to play if
they let me you know I'm gonna have a
pregame party before before the
Superbowl if I come back that would be
crazy imagine that that would be
straight not I want to bottle up Kronk's
laughs and sell it it is so good all
right question who is the last current
Patriots player that you've texted Wow
Oh Oh what do you say to a guy you say
like keep kicking ass no he wrote to me
I can't wait to hear your announcement
Tuesday and I said I can't wait for you
to hear it because it's outrageous and a
real fact
crying laughing faces and I said I said
yep that's what it is everyone probably
asks you for a Tom Brady story or a Bill
Belichick story
I want a Dante Hightower story I know
you probably battled this dude I think
he's one of the most underrated Patriots
of all time do you have a good Dante
Hightower story for me yeah I actually
do man and it when he was drafted his
rookie year we were in training camp I'm
like this dude this dude's a monster
Dante has how I mean there's some times
this guy is weighing in at 270 pounds
275 pounds back in the heyday and he
could move and I'm telling you it was it
was through his rookie year and man I
wasn't feeling I wasn't really feeling
it that well during this training camp I
was a little beat up and I couldn't get
open and he was covering me I like 270
I'm like man I couldn't even get around
him I was I didn't have my life you know
my first night that I that I needed to
get around them and like he liked his
helmet like or some
and got stuck on my shoulder pads or
something and I went and I took my
forearm and like chopped like his
facemask and he got pissed and it was
his rookie here and he got pissed and he
came and just he gave me all he had and
I was like damn this dude is a beast
right
I met him no more he was 270 and I got
him to get mad to get furious and he
came at me pretty hard and that was the
day I was like man the past got past got
a good one in this guy this dude's a
beast and he didn't even care like then
I was a vet or nothing he just brought
it and then after I gave him like I gave
him like a shivers like the Facemash or
it was like I forgot exactly what it was
his face mask like got something like
stuck to my shoulder pads but that's
when I felt his power and I knew he was
a true b7 he could do everything to
Grunk if I paid you the NFL Commissioner
tomorrow what is the first thing you
would do
man I was an fo commissioner yeah you
know I would just say I'll just put me
on uh I'll just put myself on uh you
know no waivers just a free agent at all
times
I can choose any week I could play
football I can choose any team and I
could play on any week so you would just
skip around and be like you would just
pick whoever plays the Bengals that week
I think a team and I go yeah that would
be a blast and just know you know just
for myself though I'm the only player
that's about to do this of course you're
the commissioner yeah I'm the
commissioner you know that that would be
allowed that'd be fantastic you have a 1
pick and there are two tight ends Travis
Kelce George Kittel who does Krunk pick
oh man I like to go with George you know
uh you know his game you know I just
like his game I said it before him and
he just you know try to reminds me of
myself when he hits the ball man he just
wanted to keep going just doesn't care
who's coming at him just wants to break
through all the tackles all right last
question again
we're doing this with Grunk Beach it's
gonna be a day party Saturday before the
Super Bowl go to Gronk Beach calm I see
you on TV now on Sundays on the Frog Fox
pregame show if you had to party the
entire day with one member of that show
who you bring in the South Beach hands
down Carrie Bradshaw man he's always
ready to go he's always bringing the
high energy he doesn't care what age he
is he's ready to roll at all times I
would hands down bring Terry deal Grunk
any final message for Pat Pat before you
go Pat Pat man I loved your four
questions man hopefully one day I can
satisfy your four questions and you know
if you come to the beach party Pat Pat
I'm sure you'll be happy man I know I'll
be there baby and wanted to talk to you
my friend yeah thank you thank you ma'am
see you drunk all right God have a good
day nobody better than Crump I saw that
perfectly he took kettle over Kelsey
really you know I knew he would because
he Kido plays a lot like crunk yes
Kelsey is much more of an athlete than
grow kiddo is fast in a weird way he's
not weary he is fast kid also looks for
cons but he's physical he's nasty and
and I love Kelsey that's my button
that's my guy but Kittles also my guy
and Kittel is a much better blocker than
Kelsey yeah and that was the number one
thing about Gronk is that's the reason
he's my number one Titan of all time I
believe he's also the number one
blocking Titan evolved is the biggest
man on earth and when he's on the edge
like handling defensive Tony Gonzalez
was up there what Tony didn't want to
block Kron can block yeah Algie Crumpler
Nanaji Antonio Gates was up there in one
of LA not as much of a blocker as Grunk
Kellen Winslow the original not as good
of a block and so that was my thing
about Gronk was he was like having
another tackle on the field and when it
came to mismatches like yes Kelsey can
cut up a safety but Grunk it didn't
matter if he was being guarded
you loved it up and he was taking it
from it so what Gronk was promoting by
the way was Gronk party Gronk beach he's
having a day party the Saturday before
Super Bowl on Miami Beach Wow all right
so let's play the game I said this to
him we're gonna do mad libs Gronk is
having a party at blank with
performances from blank and blank
sponsored by blank let's see if you can
get anything huh so it's at the circle
so Gronk is having a party at live South
Beach ok ok it's ok you think with
performances in Florida by Pitbull and
Trick Daddy oh you went home for two it
was Rick Ross and I with a lowrider I
would have liked Rick Ross here yeah so
those are good sponsored by monster yes
are you serious my mom's perfect I would
have got Rick Ross in dog or flora
that's what I mean they were on the list
I know they're right on there pit bull
and Trick Trick Daddy he don't know who
didn't maybe want to go old-school trick
daddies you know that trick daddy has a
song that is my number one walking
through New York song what I walk a lot
New York uh-huh
do you want to guess it's my number one
walking through New York song you and I
guess what it is I do not but I would
like to hear it you're walking down 50th
Street and you're just passing people
yeah you looking at people like this
obviously is your favorite cuz you got
it mmediately ready to go you know that
do you say that you feel better about
that damn everybody knows this song
everybody I'm telling you this in case
you haven't your phone to Matt's really
cute as Haroon I could tell it is my
color yeah but yes so he asked Krunk
would he come back
and Gronk pretty much said listen I'm
throwing a party on Saturday hey let me
throw a party on Saturday and play on
down but it was interesting because when
we signed off he kind of said to pat pat
you know listen bro I'm hope I can make
your dream come true I don't know if God
will come back but Patriots didn't
really need him yesterday you look like
he's been in the weight room no look
he's been working out no just partying
in playing football go hand in hand
sometimes but you got to be young and
it's he left the game because of
injuries obviously right Oh his body was
and it's hard to get better how you
handle all that he goes lost for last
night tough well here he is
what up left go pat pat here Colin from
my aunts house in Topsfield still
glowing after talking to my hero Rob the
Gronk Gronkowski who is easily in my top
four favorite Gronkowski brothers but
look in all seriousness I know that you
and Westbrook a big Eagles fans so I'm
gonna be gracious here I'm not gonna do
that thing where I rub it in your face
oh wait yes I friggin am suck it Eagles
we're gonna intentionally lose to the
Cowboys next we just say you guys can't
even win your own friggin piddling
division congratulations on you two
statues in your town a fictional boxer
with brain damage and a quarterback who
was immediately kicked off the team for
a guy with one leg having a conversation
with his coach riveting stuff and now
the Patriots end to every single contest
with the four best quarterbacks on the
field Tom Brady Julian Edelman my son
Jared Stidham and my dad Mohamed Sanu
senior that's right I've changed my name
from pat pat to Mohamed Sanu jr. deal
with that City Hall then by the way did
you know that the Eagles have a guy on
their Ross and a Boston Scott Boston
Scott who the hell let that happen
the Patriots didn't sign a guy named
cheesesteaks Balboa did they dad let go
come on that's bush league anyway when
nine and one now Rob Gronkowski is my
emergency contact and my apartments
guarantor and everything is right in the
world and remember it's a Vontae happy
Doc's not Avante mad Doc's pat pat aka
Mohamed Sanu jr. oh man it is
interesting that we have a Boston Scott
and a Dallas Goddard yeah yeah you know
pat pat slid something in there that I
think is Ashley
gonna happen he slid in there that
they're gonna lose to the Cowboys
Cowboys he he said attentionally I
honestly believe based on the way the
docs playing based on that defense is
not good but neither as a patriot
offense that the Cowboys do have a
chance of winning
oh absolutely I do think though the fact
that it's a New England correct I do
think it is yet at home
Dino Dallas it's gonna have to be a Zeke
game because that's how you beat the
Patriots is you have to be able to run
the ball because you really can't throw
it especially if Amari Cooper is banged
up Gilmore JC Jackson like that
secondary is phenomenal I don't know
that I think it's gonna have to be a
Zeke game I don't know that and I'll
tell you why I have the pager every
defense gets tired and the defenses get
tired because they're always on the
field their offense I mean I watched it
yesterday I will bet you a money right
now that the Patriots beat the Cowboys
are you writing this down good in
beretta I just I will never be in a
situation where I will take Jason
Garrett over Bill Belichick okay I will
not do it yeah I
that's what I'm okay with that and I
understand that and that makes sense but
in this case we're saying it's pretty
one of the hottest quarterbacks right
now when a team that hasn't run the ball
efficiently or effective in a little bit
going against a defense that actually
gallops yours stinks right Dallas
defense is terrible but the Patriots
offense who was gonna take advantage of
it nobody okay so let's talk about
Sunday night's game
Eagles Patriots because that's we do
need to address this it was said one
let's talk about the positive is for the
Eagles the defense is back okay we can
say that Tom Brady's not looking good at
the same point they got a lot of
pressure from their front four they did
Fletcher Cox looks like the Fletcher Cox
of old and Hills unblockable with Jalen
mills and Avante Maddox and Ronald Darby
out there nah it kind of looks like a
little bit the secondary starting to
make some plays and the defense like
they've needed the last few years will
be the side of the ball that can carry
the Eagles to hopefully contending for
this division now the offense
it's Jordan Matthews it's Boston Scottie
it's Nelson Aguilar and then Neal you
and a bunch of guys that you know from
your hometown are playing on the Eagles
team and and the thing is is I I am NOT
gonna face it I'm not gonna put this all
on Carson Wentz rather than a team I'm
not gonna put this on Carson Wentz did
he miss some throws at the end that were
egregious individually he missed a
couple to Nelson Aguilar dropped a
beautiful dime absolutely could he put
in a better place yes is he throwing to
Mack Hollins and Jordan Matthews and
Nelson Aguilar yes
did they when they lost Lane Johnson did
it all come crashing down very quickly
yes yes the only chance the Eagles have
to make the playoffs is by winning the
NFC East by Minnesota coming back
yesterday and beating Denver and
securing a seventh win and the Seahawks
are already having AIDS
yeah eagles ain't gettin ya it's over so
the Eagles only chance you're gonna play
they got to beat Dallas they need to run
the table with Washington Miami New York
which they will they'll do that you
don't think they'll do that I don't
think that easily I am very concerned
about this offense
I think the orphans especially of lanes
out for an extended period of time
I don't know that he is I think he may
may come back maintenance it's up dude I
was surprised he didn't come back but
obviously with that's what I'm saying if
you're carted off with a concussion yeah
this ain't a comeback soon type of well
you fight I got beat up immediately you
know playing out there a little bit
Dillard you know coming off the bench
got beat up as well
offensive issues are huge for this
football team and Carson Wentz you know
he hasn't played well 50 percent passing
yesterday missing wide-open receivers in
a pocket that he had time to throw the
football several times but also when you
get beat up at the quarterback position
you begin to see things that there
aren't there you begin to expect things
that aren't happening in front of you so
I kind of understand that at this point
Carson Wentz has no confidence in any of
the guys around him no here's a big
thing for Carson Wentz I think this is
how he improves he has to anticipate
throws
much better because right now the guys
that he has on his team they're not
gonna be wide open so in order for him
to think that for the thought process to
be these go-to guys gonna be wide open
I'm gonna throw the under football
that's not gonna happen so he has to get
off of that mindset it has to be able to
anticipate throws he has to understand
coverage is a little bit better he has
to understand is it man-to-man on this
side and zone on this side and where's
the guy that I want to throw the ball to
same thing we talked about that dak is
doing very well he all those things had
to happen and the one thing he can't
control he has to throw a good ball we
know that the one thing that he can't
control his guys catching the football
that's one of the things that you're
wondering like okay you know even though
it's a good ball and I think Nelson
Aguilar
certainly should have called the ball I
think he could have put a ball in a
better place for him quite honestly but
he certainly should have caught it the
guy's got to catch the doggone ball and
they have nobody on that team that you
can honestly say strikes fear in the
opposing defense or has the ability to
catch the ball regularly the number one
receiving weapon on the Eagles is Hertz
after the game Stephon Gilmore said I
knew I can get in his head because he's
crying all the time the second weapon on
the Eagles is Miles Sanders yes a rookie
running back that the Patriots pretty
much eliminated yesterday if you want me
to get a little bit too emotional and
you want me to point a finger I would
probably say it's because your offensive
coordinators might grow and Mike grows
last real coaching job was as an
offensive passing game coordinator for
the Rams in 2016 the Rams in 2016
oh they were really good psyche that was
the four and twelve Rams team that was
revitalized by Shaun McVeigh I also have
a huge question about the wide receivers
coach Carson Walsh who came in as an
assistant in 2018 he developed al I have
seen no development from the wide
receiving corps I have seen I don't want
to say Carson Wentz is taking a step
back but it's kind of feeling like are
someone just taking a step back this
team the offensive line play is still
pretty good the defense props to to Jim
Schwartz yes who entered Sunday allowing
35 points per game when he plays
Belichick good game plan defense is
coming along all of the creativity on
the offense is gone Bill Belichick came
out of a bye week and had
trick plays including a touchdown pass
by Edelman ready to go I read articles
today that said Belichick usually saves
these for the playoffs when you have a
lot of trick plays and you're a good
offensive mind you have them for the
playoffs you don't think that Belichick
has like 18 different plays the fact
that the Eagles offense couldn't do
anything after Lane Johnson left and
they found no ways to to spark it at all
they didn't have a trick play after they
had a bye week in a big-time game
against the Patriots where you know you
are fighting for your life I have a lot
of issues this coaching staff grant it
they have been better when their back is
against the wall
in years past well guess what that's the
sound of your back hittin the wall it's
time in order to have trick plays I'll
just push back here you got to have
someone to throw it and someone to catch
it and those are two areas they have
more faith in Nelson Aguilar throwing
balls than I do in catching who's going
to catch it yeah
Hertz Goddard okay Jay Cho the explosive
play is which is what this team is is
missing explosive plays down the field
they have nothing down the field
everything is within 10 15 yards of the
line of scrimmage that's a problem
that's easy for defenses to a listen I
want Stephon Gilmore play yesterday
without really having a break a jog I
mean it was just like uh I'll just drop
back to Brown Street if any of them B
I'll drop that because the 15 yards and
just watch everything and then just make
a tackle and and to point out a couple
of different things there was uh several
times where the the the Patriots knew
exactly where to be yet they're running
the same place just to your point
there's no creativity you came out of
the by running the same things expecting
the Patriots seemed that you knew would
win it to the by pissed off because they
got blown out by the Ravens and thought
that they were just gonna do something
different no Super Bowl confidence meter
Super Bowl meters down is it's below
zero it's negative you're back to
negative yes to win the Super Bowl yeah
that's the reason we don't think we
don't think their day we're gonna make
the playoffs they're not gonna win a
Super Bowl they're not prepared
offensively to win a Super Bowl right
now
they can't they can't score with the
better teams in the enemies like they
did they play Green Bay right now they
wouldn't beat him like they did earlier
on in the season they can't beat the the
Saints they can't beat I mean there's a
but I don't think that you think the
soda do you believe the Eagles are done
for this season I don't think that
they'll beat Dallas which i think is
gonna be the biggest game of the season
I don't think they beat Dallas when they
come to Philly and in that's because I
think dak is playing well I think they
they still do have a rushing attack even
though it hasn't been very good and I
think the Eagles offense is below
average as bad as I thought the Patriots
offense was yesterday I look at the
Eagles offenses like you know what
they're not much better if if at all
better most people would say worse who's
the guy that you have confidence on an F
football team Myles Sanders a little bit
maybe hurts hurts got hurt
Jordan Howard when he's healthy okay
what about the guys that played
yesterday yeah hurts mouth Sanders a
little bit maybe got it a little bit she
was two young guys changing or a thing
exactly
he caught he did catch the ball you know
one time keep Patriots though like
they're just they're just they're piling
up wins and though they'll hit their
stride when they need to I don't believe
that I think I think the Patriots
normally hit their stride when they need
to
I saw something yesterday from Tom Brady
that shocked me there was a couple
passes out passes to the running backs
little dump ball passes where he just he
couldn't get the ball to him there five
six yards away couldn't get the ball to
him at all and I'm not saying his arm is
dead cuz he ended up throwing one deep
and he was able to get a deep but
there's a bunch of balls that Tom
Brady's bad as Carson Wentz I thought
played Tom Brady didn't play better
he didn't I'll play him he made a couple
plays when he needed to but the best the
best passes that Tom Brady threw
yesterday were screens that's that's
what Tom Brady had going on and you add
to that that their offensive line is
average at best you may get wind back at
some point but their average at best
that's a problem
are you selling on the Patriots right
now do I think they can win the a of
see no well no you know I don't think
that either obviously I think they can
well yeah I mean of course they well
obviously like a Tina bead and the
Chiefs are scary but like I don't think
they waitress you don't and here's why I
tell you tell it was it say why because
offensively let's just say against the
Chiefs right whose defense is horrible I
don't know that the Patriots have the
ability to put up a bunch of points
against the Chiefs I still think the
Chiefs did for three weeks I think the
Chiefs are scored 24 27 points against
the Patriots I don't know that the pages
are scored 27 points I don't know that
so you don't you definitely don't think
the Patriots are going to the Superbowl
no I don't I don't think they win the
AFC I don't you you believe that you
believe that after watching what they
did yesterday I believe this will never
catch me dead well saying that only yeah
that was that's the old thought process
so how is it that you're many timers
media member to call them dead how many
how is it that so many times you want to
let's get out of our mind about the old
quarterback thought process and now
we're Lamar Jackson and you can watch
the Patriots and you're basing your
thought on the Patriots on the old
thought oh Tom Brady we'll figure it out
we're who who's coming back cuz Groff's
not there no more Edelman still will get
his we understand that Mohamed Sanu
who I thought was a great pick up I
think he's still gonna be okay but he
looks pretty slow Lamar Jackson is like
Luke Skywalker yes and he's gonna enter
a place where he's gonna meet the Dark
Lord okay Emperor mm-hmm and that's Bill
Belichick yeah I don't care if Jared
Stidham was at quarterback Rex Burkhead
was there starting wide receiver and
they decided to move Isaiah win to tight
end yeah I will never bet against the
Patriots because I have never seen
somebody like Bill Belichick I'm not
doubting Brady and I will possibly bet
another money with you right now
the Patriots I don't want to I don't
want to go several so I don't wanna make
the bet you know you know why I want to
root for the Patriots the Patriots again
I think I just I want you to know that I
don't it's hard for me to not interrupt
people yes
but I saw where you were going there and
I said I can't believe westbrook's gonna
do this and I just watched you do it it
was like an out-of-body experience cuz I
just didn't I you know why I just can't
believe because I I've watched this team
I've watched the Patriots over the last
few weeks like observed them just watch
them how do they play how to do a roster
thing yeah all those thanks great it's
great but let's look at look how many
points they scored 20 Baltimore yeah I
think Baltimore's better now than they
were a couple weeks ago 17 yesterday 20
mile-per-hour winds
struggling yesterday to get 17 quite
honestly well look we're gonna learn a
lot about the Pats in the next three
weeks average for two home games one a
road game Dallas at Houston home against
the Chiefs there's a chance that these
next three games Dallas Houston Casey
that they may be one in three give me
one and two one to correct math yes you
don't you don't agree with that I would
agree with you on this
I agree with you with that in terms of
this the Patriots usually have one part
of the year where people go oh maybe
it's ending usually it's in week five
but in week five this year it was
Washington New York Jets Cleveland right
I could see them having a dip right now
and I can see the world turning and
people going oh no maybe they're not as
good as we said schedules and all that
they're still gonna get a bye yes and
they're still gonna become in the
playoffs and be incredible and so I I
just know that there are death taxes and
Belichick making Super Bowl runs and and
they all included a great security
blanket and Rob Gronkowski and on third
and seven to your earlier point Gronk
will be at the Super Bowl to your
earlier point 37 Artie there's nobody
that can stop him they don't have that
guy anymore they just don't have them
let me introduce you to Nikhil Harry
that's a beautiful place to end can't
believe you said that
yeah it's true more power to everybody
that watches them believes it you don't
want to believe it because their past
I'm looking at today 2019 Patriots not
what Bill Belichick did in the last 19
years of our lives are you prepared for
this take to like be all over bleacher
report it's time
think that that's that's gonna be
shocking is that shocking the people
really
it can't be sake no listen you ever hear
the story of David when he reached into
a I think a hot coals and he burned his
hand he put his mouth and he got a lisp
and he just realized not to put his
hands no never heard that story yeah I
have heard of David in the Calliope
how about him David in the was it Daniel
in the lion's den one of those guys the
Lions dad I'm just worried about you men
I want this Patriot teaming to be the
team of old that you think that they are
they're not that team and Tom Brady
almost do another interception yesterday
all right
dead man walking it was nice to know us
president of real you're about to enter
a weird world you can't tell me that
that Patriot office looks good they
don't and neither does your money I am
shocked for Westbrook the rocket man I
have the lef koe Man for David Ingeborg
for pat pat and Rob Gronkowski
Westbrook I'll see you on the other side
pal sounds good brother holy crap
[Music]